I'm current ID enough to join us on
short notice we have them on speed dial
Patriots insider for NBC sports Boston
we're looking for a good scandal here
do we have one Tom oh yeah it it'll rise
to the level of good scandal just
because it harkens back to exactly what
the Patriots got pinched for in 2007 I
don't in any way shape or form believe
that the football side of things said
hey do us a solid go to Cleveland and
make sure you wear your Patriots jersey
and videotape the sidelines during the
game because nobody will think twice
about it but it's just too juicy excuse
me it's just too juicy to go away all
right what are they accused of like you
know is how serious is this it's going
to be serious in the eyes of the league
because of the appearances and in the
same way I think that deflategate rose
to something that Roger Goodell was a
hanging judge with this will be the same
to a degree again to a degree I don't
make any predictions on what the
punishment will be but they're accused
of having a videographer in the press
box in Cleveland who directed while they
were playing the Cincinnati Bengals this
week's upcoming opponent having a video
camera directed at the Bengals sideline
during the first quarter of Sunday's
game Bengals staffer alerted the NFL the
NFL said we're taking the tape bengals
said the same thing according to ESPN's
Dianna Rossini the staffer said can't we
just delete this and forget all about it
which doesn't look that awesome but the
Patriots explanation is that the
Patriots in-house content production arm
used to be called Kraft sports
productions
does the series called do your job which
is basically you know you'd follow
fritzy around and videotape him calling
guests and stuff and then you put it out
and say here this is how fritzy does
this job well that's what this guy was
doing with an advance scout so logically
I guess the videographer thought well
it's probably a good idea to take video
of what he looks at during
we did that how you could think that was
a great idea and not have the
institutional knowledge if you work for
the Patriots that if you hold a video
camera you never do that I don't know
but that's where we're gonna be dead but
it always starts out small Tom these
things always start out small and then
it feels like they mushroom you know if
deflategate it started out small
laughter on Monday yeah I'm laughed on
Monday now I've heard everything he said
on the radio when I go back to though
and I'm his Bill Belichick during the
mona lisa veto press conference and i
would encourage you guys to go find this
in the next couple hours because it's
really interesting he's asked about
Spygate
during that press conference by an
Associated Press reporter Belichick the
answer was this and I'll I'll read it to
you
I mean look that's a whole other
discussion the guy's giving signals in
front of 80,000 people okay so we filmed
them taking signals in front of 80,000
people like a lot of other teams we're
doing at the end he says so it was wrong
we were disciplined that's it we never
did it again we're never going to do it
again and anything else that's close
we're not going to do either and both
sides that's why I'm like I thought they
couldn't write yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
okay so here we are so we're done you
wrote the column that sort of laid the
breadcrumbs down that Tom Brady would
leave this franchise I don't know if
it's mutual or by his own accord there
and I was curious did you hear from
Brady after you wrote that not directly
no indirectly I don't think he was
pissed do you think that he thought you
were accurate I wasn't told that I was
inaccurate
[Laughter]
if you were if you were betting a week's
pay oh man Patriots retire other other
okay could you see a scenario where josh
mcdaniels and tom brady are a package
deal in carolina no I think that that
owner is gonna be far too involved for
Josh McDaniels to think that's a great
landing spot however given Josh's I
spear might I want to waver on that just
a little by saying he had such a tepid
response to his candidacy last year with
only Green Bay really stepping forward
maybe he would entertain that idea only
Green Bay gave an interview last year
but I think he wants to make sure that
he's in a position where he's got you
know all the sway and Marty Ernie's
there I also wonder with all the
struggles that Brady has had you know
you know in the last couple of months
here does that sort of reinforce the
thought process of you know what maybe
it is time for me to get out of here on
know on Tom's part Oh certainly yeah I
think certainly it is because you know
he's looking at okay they haven't gone
over the moon to satisfy my contract
demands and what have they done with the
money saved well I can't really tell
when I come out of the huddle and look
around at the guys I'm surrounded by I
mean I have an undrafted rookie I have a
first-round draft pick who's over on the
sidelines because when it comes in
things don't go so good I have Phillip
Dorsett to the Colts left out at the end
of their driveway
I have no tight end and I have chills
god bless them and that's it so I think
that there are points of which that's
why I said in the story Dan that I think
it could be an amicable split if indeed
the split comes to pass and this just
comes down to this is Bill Belichick's
decision right I think that in the fight
yeah and the final analysis it would be
bill maybe having to do some convincing
of ownership but yeah I think it would
be a football decision Deion Sanders had
a comment a couple of weeks ago where
you
his cryptic but he said he was
guaranteeing the Patriots were gonna add
a playmaker here by the end of the
season who who is that playmaker
I think that Deon might have been
referring to Dez Bryant because he and
Dez Bryan are extremely close and he is
in the past lobbied for him to go to but
now is he advocating or is he's
advocating not acting I think it's more
of an advocacy than a prediction maybe
they do sign him but how does that help
I mean they had Josh wood and they had
Demaryius Thomas I'm not even gonna
mention Antonio Brown because what he
did to shoot his way out of town people
he's conveniently forgetting he
threatened the children of the woman who
wasn't even really accusing him in a
Sports Illustrated story it just it it
buggers the mind Dan yeah but you have
guys in that locker room who were saying
hey we're okay with having him back
right right right
okay since then I mean they were all
okay with having them back as a football
player but I think that they don't have
to say what damage that does to the
brand of the New England Patriots when a
player is on the team who has done
something like that they just want to
win the football games and I don't blame
them do your job your job is to win the
games if you need good players around
you do that if you're Robert Kraft the
job is to protect the brand as well to
make sure that it is marketable and
having him on the field tracks from that
so that's where the rubber met the road
with that decision Tom it's good to talk
to you again as always we've done again
a spat fast well am I gonna see you the
Super Bowl sure yeah who will you be
covering well it's gonna be I would
imagine it's probably gonna be a Ravens
Ravens 49ers rape okay
all right don't you think it's starting
to look like that but you know we get
things happen in the postseason yeah
because can you see a scenario where you
the Patriots have lost to the Chiefs
they lost to the Texans a loss to the
Ravens can that be a positive for this
team the next time around whoever they
meet only defensively only defensively I
don't care who they're playing in terms
of what they can do offensively they
can't get over 20 points right now I'll
be stunned if they get over 20 points
more than once in the final three games
here and they haven't done it in a
couple of weeks so well I got 22 last
week against Houston but anyway how much
money to go hurt though I don't mean to
make wait wait no no how much will it
hurt if Garoppolo wins the Super Bowl it
shouldn't hurt because the Patriots got
their post Garoppolo Super Bowl win last
year and a post Garoppolo Super Bowl
appearance but you know how we are up
here with great new you but you feel and
you're yelling and it feels like you're
being defensive I was just asking a
question
I'm only defensive because I just think
it made perfect sense to move on from
Jim Jim
Thank You Tom Tom all right yeah we're
not a couple of month yeah and to sue
much yeah all right all right see you
thanks for having night I can't miss you
if you don't go that's Tom Curren NBC
Sports Boston for more Dan Patrick show
tune in to audience channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on be our live
or download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]